technology gives us the ability to
create relationships in the supply chain
relationships between producers and
consumers much more flexibly and rapidly
we're seeing it already in food
production in transport resources such
as journeys in cars and parking spaces
and we're seeing it in the in the
manufacture of custom goods so the image
on the bottom left is taken from
Shapeways where you can 3d print pretty
much anything that you like and the cost
of this technology is coming down at the
same time these marketplaces are
transactional and we've got interesting
opportunities to affect the rate of
exchange used in those transactions
there's an alternative currency that's
been in use in Switzerland for nearly a
hundred years now the we're that's
thought to have contributed to economic
stability there suspect with someone
from the lse chairing the debate we may
have a comment on that five towns and
cities in the UK I'll have their own
local currencies now with similar
intentions and they're increasingly
using advanced technology to support
those currencies such as the droplet
smartphone payment system that's been
created in Birmingham these rates of
exchange offer us the possibility to
compare the complete cost of goods and
services the financial costs and their
social and environmental implications
with dynamic locally localized value to
the participants what it's worth to me
now to have this service rather than
what it might be worth to me to have it
in two weeks time when I really need it
I think there's tremendous potential
here to produce new information based
marketplaces that could support more
sustainable city systems but if there's
such a good idea why don't we have them
ubiquitously already and that comes down
to something that's been mentioned by
the other by the other speakers where
cities are making progress on this
agenda it's where they're coordinating
the use of their public sector and
private sector assets towards a
co-created vision towards a common set
of goals and objectives but in order to
win that level of commitment you don't
only need to buy in of the leaders and
managers of those resources you need the
understanding of all of the stakeholders
that there
accountable to their employees the
electorate's their shareholders to
appeal to that tremendously broad set of
interests we need to I think to appeal
to some common instincts amongst us all
a sense of narrative and our ability to
empathize rather than focus on the
financial efficiencies created by smart
infrastructures and if we do that we may
not get very far because smart ideas cut
across silos so those who realize the
benefits may not be those who are asked
to make the investment in the first case
instead we should be concentrating on
the social and personal and community
value that can be created when people
can connect it can afford to buy better
food where they can afford to heat their
homes properly in winter when they have
access to affordable transport to places
of employment